my personal favorites
my first one is sasha fierce that
sublime double album the second one
would be lemonade
the third one is a bit of a toss up
between two it's no secret that adele is
a bona fide member of the beehive she is
my
icon of my whole life and now she's
ranking her all-time favorite beyonce
albums you know that could be
controversial the hive might come and
kill me the easy on me singer dishes on
queen bee as part of vogue's 73
questions specifically she was asked to
tackle the difficult task of ranking the
crazy in love singer's albums my
personal favorites
my first one is sasha fierce that
sublime double album the second one
would be lemonade
the third one is a bit of a toss up
between two but i'm gonna go with my gut
and my heart and i'm gonna say b-day of
course back in 2017 adele's album 25 won
album of the year over lemonade at the
grammys
my album of the year is lemonade adele
took home five grammys that night while
beyonce won best urban contemporary
album and best music video and during
adele's album of the year acceptance
speech she let her feelings be known
my artist of my life is beyonce in this
album for me
the lemonade album was just
so monumental after finishing her speech
she also opened up about it backstage
like i said in my speech for me my album
of the year was lemonade um so
a piece of me did die inside as a
beyonce stan i'm not going to lie um
because i was completely rooting for her
i voted for her obviously the visual is
very
new and you know it's and the grammys
are very traditional and i am of course
very very grateful having won here um
but i felt the need because i love her
because
i felt like she was more than worthy and
she meant it so much so that she broke
her trophy in half on the grammy stage
to share it with v
was breaking your grammy in half for
beyonce easier or harder than you
thought it would be it was actually
really easy i was just so uncomfortable
and nervous up on the stage trying to
give that speech right in front of her
and just sort of twist it off and fell
off from the end it felt like fate
but beyonce wasn't the only music legend
adele swooned over what's the proudest
possession that you own
it's actually inside okay what do we
have here
it's pretty amazing all right
celine dion's
gum
yeah adele has celine dion's gum
framed on her wall a gift from james
corden after celine appeared on his
segment carpool karaoke
[Music]
james corden who's a friend of mine but
also does carpool karaoke which i did uh
he did it with her and knew how much a
fan of her i was and so he made her spit
her gum into piece of paper he framed it
for me
and it's my proudest possession and this
is just one of many reasons why we love
adele i'm very very humbled obviously
things like this and of course her
incredible voice
[Music]
but we aren't the only ones moved to
tears by the 33 year old singer's music
even adele makes adele cry
do you cry while singing any of your
songs
i do to quite a few of my new ones yeah
oh wow so how does she rank her favorite
adele tracks someone like you would be
number one
i think there's a new song on um the new
album that would be my number second or
be my second one and then when we were
young i really love that song i love
singing it means a lot to me fans are
also eagerly awaiting the release of
adele's fourth studio album rumored to
be called 30 which will drop on november
19th the lead single easy on me has
already broken several streaming records
[Music]
but in the spirit of adele's favorite
i'll send you off with this
everybody loves the things you do
from the way you talk
to the way you move
everybody here is watching you
cause you feel like home